77 à Genève elle est morte noyée en
Algérie en 1904 c'està-dire elle a
seulement 27 ans 27 ans de vie et
pourtant qu'elle vit quelle singulière
vie que c'est que que la sienne oui en
effet c'est Isabelle ebrart en fait a
connu la célébrité que Postume c'était
une jeune russe euh avec un passeport
tariste et qui a été élevé à Genève de
parents
immigrés qui a été élevé de la plus
étrange façon puisqu'elle n'a jamais été
à l'école son père était son prcep était
son précepteur et elle a dès son plus
jeune âge mettons vers ses 13 14 14 15
ans elle a été obsédée par l'islam le
Maghreb et apprendre la langue apprendre
l'arabe alors qu'elle parlait déjà cinq
langues elle était donc très cosmopolite
au départ et de façon très curieuse sa
famille la pe-être involontairement
poussé dans ce désir puisque ces deux
frères russes également ont fait fugue
sur le premier s'est échappé et s'est
engagé à la Légion étrangère et le
deuxième oui mais je vis qu'on parler on
parlera tout à l'heure des frères de la
famille qui était des personnages incroy
vous me disiez tout de suite pourquoi
elle est extraordinaire cette femme elle
est extraordinaire parce qu'elle a fait
ce que personne n'a fait avant elle et
ce que à moi ma connaissance personne
n'a fait après elle elle est partie
seule pour l'Afrique sans av voir
vraiment personne qui pouvait la sauver
en cas de maladie en cas de difficulté
et elle est partie à la découverte de
l'Algérie et d'une Algérie qui était le
contraire de ce que en général les
écrivains allaient chercher dans les
pays du Maghreb c'est-à-dire ils
allaient chercher un Maghreb mythique
des harêes des palais de la richesse
elle elle a vu l'Algérie au quotidien
elle a suivi la route des caravanes je
crois que c'est Albert Londres qui dit
qu'il y a deux races d'hommes ceux qui
ont des Valis
et ceux qui ont des meubles et bien elle
n'avait ni ni meubles ni valise elle
avait un balluchon et elle est partie à
la découverte d'un pays qui était occupé
qui était colonialement occupé par les
Français et elle s'est trouvé tout de
suite partagée entre le désir d'aimer ce
peuple et en même temps elle n'était pas
antifrançaise et considérit que
peut-être la France a porté beaucoup à
l'Algérie et elle n'a été publié elle a
commencé à devenir journaliste quand
elle a été publiée par un journal bilain
qui n'était pas le plus populaire de
l'Algérie qui s'appelait l'akbar et elle
a commencé là à faire une carrière de
journaliste disons de journaliste assez
limité spécial et elle a été publiée et
n'a connu de gloire que Postume quand
ces écrits ont commencé à paraître après
sa mort mais on voit bien ce qui vous
plaît c'est que c'est une irrégulière
pour reprendre un de vos titres célèbres
c'est une femme scandaleuse pour
l'époque c'est sûrement une femme
scandaleuse oui parce qu'on a bien voulu
qu'elle le soit je crois qu'elle ne m'a
intéressé surtout que parce qu'elle
était une immigrée une étrangère et que
cela me paraissait intéressant d'essayer
de comprendre comment d'une jeune fille
aventureuse à force d'en faire une
suspecte on finit par en faire une
réprouvée et que je considérais que
c'était un sujet assez actuel puisque il
y a beaucoup d'étrangersoui et j'ajoute
ai là je vous cite russe elle fut le
premier écrivain maghrébain d'expression
française ce qui n'est quand même pas
rien non absolument elle après elle a
elle a vrai été la première à considérer
qu'il n'y avait pas de langue plus
importante l'une que l'autre et que on
pouvait s'exprimer en français mais à
condition de mettre ce Français à la
vraiment à la disposition des Algériens